On February 22, 2022, a car crash in Chicago
escalated when one of the two drivers pulled
a gun and shot the other one in the leg.
While we don’t know much about the suspect,
we can assume that she had, at that instant,
limited capacity for sympathy, self-awareness,
empathy, meta-cognition and theory of mind.
In short, she could have lacked social intelligence
and misinterpreted the incident as a deliberate
attack.
Social intelligence is the capacity to know
oneself and to know others — sometimes referred
to as "tact", "common sense", or "street smarts".
It's an innate human trait of neurotypical
minds, that gets refined through experience
with people, and learning from success and
failure in social settings.
Five distinct cognitive skills are at its
core.
Sympathy is our tendency to feel with others.
Parents naturally sympathize with their child.
And babies experience stress when their mothers
are sad.
As we grow up, most of us show a lot of sympathy
for our family, some for our close circle
of friends and less for strangers.
Self-awareness is the ability to understand
our feelings.Toddlers that indicate they are
hungry display that capacity.
If they throw tantrums, it’s often because
they don’t understand their emotions.
Although some are explicitly told not to express
what they feel.
As we get older we gain better self-awareness.
Some people remain confused by their feelings
because they have learned to suppress them.
Empathy is our ability to understand what
others are feeling.
Some children begin to show empathy as early
as kindergarten.
Others seem to lack this ability even when
they are far older.
Through years of social experiences we can
refine our empathy.
But those who never quite learned to understand
their own emotions, may also never learn to
sense the feelings of others.
Metacognition is an awareness of one's own
thought processes.
At age 4 most children display the first forms
of metacognitive skills when they begin to
show what they know and what they don't know.
Soon after they learn to assess their level
of confidence in their own knowledge.
As adults, many of us get to know our brain
and learn that one of its jobs is to bring
order to an inherently chaotic world of fact
and fiction.
Some, however, get trapped in the stories
and lies they tell themselves to be true.
They don’t see that their minds can get
stuck in a web of biases.
They remain unaware that they may be wrong
about certain assumptions.
Theory of mind is our ability to understand
what others know and how they think.
Children start to demonstrate theory of mind
around the age of 6.
They then realize that others may have different
information, and as a result draw different
conclusions.
This often leads to more empathy.
As adults, theory of mind allows us to understand
another person's perspective and their pattern
of thought.
Which makes it a powerful skill for influencing
others.
So sympathy, and self-awareness help us to
understand our emotions and meta-cognition
our thoughts.
They provide us with knowledge about ourselves.
Empathy allows us to appreciate what others
feel and theory of mind what goes on in their
heads: they allow us to understand others.
Social intelligence is always formed within
a particular culture, which means we might
be clueless when put into a new social setting.
So while all 5 aspects are universally present,
they need to be refined for each particular
society.
Animals, by the way, show sympathy and empathy.
Chimps even show a rudimentary ability for
theory of mind.
Humans, however, are the most socially intelligent
of all species.
What do you think?
Where does our high social intelligence come
from and how could we develop the five traits
further to increase our understanding of each
other?
Share your thoughts in the
comments below.